[Music]
hello and welcome to drive with the DW
car show coming up three Drive systems
for the hyundai ioniq we test the hybrid
version porsche on quest for a record at
the Nurburgring and the new Mercedes
s-class
[Music]
now mafia consciousness on Chicana
wouldn't say the Mercedes s-class
actually needed a facelift even after
four years but it's going to keep its
benchmark status it has to keep its
technology state-of-the-art from the
outside the facelift is not readily
apparent but a closer look at the grille
and the bumper reveals slight
differences the real improvements are
under the hood Sascha points out that
traditionally the s500 had always had a
v-8 now it's powered by an inline
6-cylinder engine he wonders how the
cars fans will receive it should the S
500 have really had a v-8 he'll check
out the performance and sound to decide
for himself the 320 kilowatt output of
the three liter inline 6 does come close
to that of the 4.7 liter v8 used up to
now but it needs a good sized
turbocharger to do it that builds
exhaust gas pressure in the lower rev
range
so Mercedes has given its r6 an electric
booster compressor it kicks in right
from the rock bottom rev range giving
the engine a good 520 Newton metres of
torque at just 1800 reps before the
turbocharger takes over and that's the
end of turbo lag an integrated starter
generator sandwiched between engine and
transmission Spurs on the gasoline
engine the moment the cars ruling
[Music]
when Gotham's Sasha explains that since
it takes a lot of fuel to set this
nearly two-ton street cruiser in motion
the electric boost can help reduce fuel
consumption by a good 22 percent among
the fuel saving tweaks is the coasting
function and the driver won't be called
upon to switch off the Eco start/stop
system as the starter generator is
always at the ready never as saving fuel
been this fun the electric drive also
supplies the 48 volt electrical system
recuperative braking helps to charge the
battery which is stowed under the rear
seats the primary electrics also supply
the windshield heating taking it to the
right temperature faster and the air
conditioning keeps running when the car
is standing still personally Sasha quite
likes the inline six-cylinder engine
he's pleasantly surprised especially by
the electric motor but to make a real
comparison you'll have to drive the v8
version like this s 560 it'll be
interesting to see how much of a
difference to the inline 6 you'll be
able to feel angles on toshite sometimes
axle in the mud
such a likes the sound much better when
he steps on the gas in the S 560 it has
better pick up as well now he finds the
difference greater than he's expected at
first he realizes the inline six just
can't measure up to the v8 when he
considers only the specs the difference
seems to be greater subjectively than
objectively the S 500s starter generator
can briefly give the combustion engine
up to 250 Newton meters of torque and 16
kilowatts of additional power the
interior has a very high-class feel to
it whether in front or back the
spaciousness and find materials create
an atmosphere of elegance to enhance the
wellness factor of its luxury class even
further mercedes has given it an ambient
lighting system capable of 64 colors
with individually adjustable zones the
only space for Sasha and in his class is
behind the wheel but not all s-class
buyers have to or want to drive it
themselves so it's important to make
sure it has plenty of room and back is
1.92 meter frame has more than enough
space even with four people in the car
his knees don't bump into the seat in
front but should any more room be needed
the front seat can be moved forward from
the rear to create the kind of legroom
offered by business class airplane seats
business improved so I list a few by
flight to experience real luxury all
that's needed in the s-class is the
remote control to switch on the
energizing comfort program it presents a
selection of music fragrance and hot
stone massage for a well tempered
atmosphere a wellness the lighting is a
part of it
passengers in back can be prodded and
caressed to their desired state of
vitality it can make all the difference
on long hauls or heading to this or that
important meeting but personally Sasha
doesn't feel that he needs it especially
since the combinations of options don't
come cheap
mystic in the community one
the price list has the energizing
comfort at just 238 euros but the
relatively low extra charge only comes
together with more expensive extras like
the ambient lighting for 476 euros and
the air balance package for 440 euros
the extras really start adding up with
the active multi-contour front and rear
seats including a massage function for
just over 2,000 and just over one
thousand eight hundred fifty euros
respectively local multi fogger
Sascha returns to the question does an S
500 have to have a v8 he wouldn't say so
the inline 6-cylinder engine with
electric drive would definitely be
enough for him but for the sound and
prestige of a v8 a car buyer will have
to go for the S 560 the S class starts
at 85 thousand euros in Germany and the
S 500 list for 103 thousand a v8 engine
will attack another ten thousand euros
on to that and if you want to go right
to the limits you can try out the AMG S
65 with a price tag of some 240,000
euros that's another story entirely
spun at 40,000 overall scheme understand
the guns and a shifter
[Music]
with the Leon Cupra STC odd is now
offering a sporty station wagon meant to
combine practical family needs and the
racecar feel how does it do car tester
Emmanuel Schaefer takes it for a spin on
Austria's Vaako ring he's interested to
see how long it will take this car to
convince him Lezyne belong in stoic
pajamas you both saw it at a length of
some 4.55 meters it already gets points
for roominess but we'll get to that
later now we'll take it for a spin on
the race track with a 221 kilowatt
output the all-wheel drive makes the
spring from 0 to 100 km/h in under 5
seconds with a top speed of 250 km/h
even our tester is impressed by those
figures his verdict driving the Cupra on
a race track is a lot of fun the
all-wheel drive really helps with
acceleration out of the curves
so it's clearly fun to drive that's no
wonder since the adaptive chassis
control reacts to road conditions within
milliseconds this station wagon stays
true to the design standards of the Leon
series looking quite similar to its
tamer siblings but a few small details
reveal what's hiding underneath the
performance package options include
Brembo brakes for the right amount of
deceleration 19-inch alloy wheels
underscore its sporty character as do
the spoiler and the dual exhaust pipes
in the interior sports seats provide the
right support
the Cupra logo is embossed on the
integrated headrests and how does it
stack up on space the manual says
there's definitely enough room to sit
comfortably even over long journeys the
seats are comfortable and there's plenty
of headroom the rest of the interior
makes a tidy impression since most of
the functions are controlled by a
touchscreen with the exception of the
air conditioning settings which is a
good thing the trunk offers a generous
587 litres of cargo space the Leon St
Cooper 300 starts at 35,000 780 euros in
Germany
thanks both for coming Abbi Manawa says
this car delivers on its promise as a
roomie family car with the ancient power
of a race car
it's convinced him that it's truly the
best of both worlds
after just three years BMW is giving its
two series a facelift
BMW traditionally calls this
modernization lifecycle impulse in the
case of the two series this impulse is
gentle the standard by LED headlamps
have a new design that there's a little
closer to the traditional kidney shape
the 2 Series Convertible service in
thirty four thousand two hundred euros
in Germany rolls-royce presents the
eighth generation of the luxury sedan
the Phantom the architecture of luxury
is an aluminium space frame and is
slated to be the foundation of all
future rolls-royce models the British
flagship manufactured is powered by a 12
cylinder engine with 420 kilowatts and
900 Newton meters of torque the set F
transmission as eight speeds
[Music]
enter stop contest irani lipstick is
presenting the hyundai ioniq which is
available with three drivetrains hybrid
plug-in hybrid and all-electric today
he's testing the hybrid version to see
if it can compete with the likes of the
Toyota Prius the nameplate ionic is a
portmanteau of ion an electrically
charged particle and unique and what is
unique is the selection of power trains
for this model
the hyundai ioniq hybrids highly
aerodynamic design has certainly
praiseworthy its kupe style profile
there's certain similarities to the
familiar hybrid models by Toyota and
Honda but where the South Korean car
really sets itself apart to its
advantage is in the details
the hyundai ioniq shares his powertrain
with the kia Niro
[Music]
the integrated rear spoiler helps with
the aerodynamics but can get in the way
of a clear view when reversing or
maneuvering luckily a backup camera is
standard
[Music]
at a length of four point 47 meters the
five CD offers plenty of room the back
seat is comfortable even for adults the
trunk offers 443 litres of space
expandable to 1505 litres when you fold
down the back seat but the loading sill
is impractical sitting 76 centimeters
above the ground and rising and ungainly
21 centimeters above the bed the
lipstick says the front sight lines are
good despite the flat windshield but the
split rear view window hinders the view
and back the price of a good drag
coefficient value the hybrid has a 1.6
liter gasoline direct injection engine
that provides 77 kilowatts of power and
an electric motor with 32 kilowatts the
total system output is 104 kilowatts
with a maximum torque of 265 Newton
meters the manufacturer claims it'll go
100 kilometers on 3.9 liters of gas
Ronnie says it's not a sports car though
the test car's tuning suggests the
engineers were hoping for more power it
can joke unpleasantly over bumps and
although the seats are comfortable they
are thinly upholstered and you feel
those bumps the interior is clear-cut
the front seats are sufficiently
contoured though the sides could be more
defined in the shoulder region most of
the controls are placed where you'd
expect to find them and the main display
is at a nearly optimal height
[Music]
the audio system an SD navigation system
our standard BAC controls consist of
clear large buttons but the position is
a bit low the style and premium packages
offer the option of inductive smart
phone charging the hyundai ioniq hybrid
is going after the hybrid plan here the
Toyota Prius has more agile handling and
a dual clutch automatic transmission it
also avoids polarizing aesthetics and
costs about 5,000 euros less brownie
sums things up by saying that the
hyundai ioniq will appeal to
environmentally minded city drivers who
like wedge shapes it offers extensive
features and fuel efficiency but drivers
shouldn't expect it to set their hearts
on fire
when it comes to testing both race cars
and street-legal cars there's a
benchmark that all car makers base
things on the North Loop of the
Nurburgring racetrack
it's nearly 21 kilometers long was 73
curves and more than 300 meters of
elevation change car makers run tests
here and try to break records it's just
the right track for Porsches newest Road
vehicle the 911 gt3 with 368 kilowatts
of power Lisa from Porsche says the best
car is the one that covers the distance
in the shortest time he says that if
you're fast enough on the Nurburgring
it'll be fast enough anywhere in the
world
Nouveau King snellius this revival of
the village smell but the North Loop is
different from most race courses since
it features a challenging variable
driving surface posting a good time on
this track means a huge boost to your
image the North Luth puts a considerable
strain on tires so to get the best time
Porsche changes the tires after each lap
[Music]
Beleza explains that to set records
preparation has to be perfect the tires
have to be there everything has to have
been carefully planned and the drivers
have to have practiced the weather has
to cooperate and the team has to be
highly motivated after months of
meticulous preparation everything is
focused on just a few minutes when
everything has to work perfectly
Porsche is using tires their customers
will also get on their gt3 their sporty
semi slicks made specifically for the
gt3 is pointing up from Porsche says the
main thing is drivability on the North
Loop in particular the driver has to
trust the vehicle getting feedback from
the car and be able to anticipate its
reactions that's the only way to get the
car to the limit and reach top speeds a
lot of power or great tires aren't
enough everything has to be well matched
to achieve the absolute optimal result
it's muscle its woven and the up custom
signed us is perfect to optimal scope
the clock is ticking now everything has
to be just right only the best of the
best managed to stay below 7 minutes and
20 seconds on a lap of the North Loop
and among those is the new gt3
[Music]
it manages a lap time of seven minutes
12 seconds and 7/10 the engineers are
thrilled with the results of their hard
work race car driver lars karen says he
felt relaxed driving the car it
responded well and he didn't have any
critical moments during the two laps he
says they knew the car had the potential
to make that time and he says it's
important for it to be easy for the
customer to experience he thinks that
won't be a problem if I'm fire faba is
offered in Kuhn diocese relative to
safety
Porsche proved its mettle on the North
Loop back in 2013 with its super sports
car the 918 Spyder the company was the
first to post a North Loop lap time of
under seven minutes with a series
production street-legal vehicle this
time another 918 is being put to the
test
[Music]
and Porsche easily confirms the
potential of its radical hybrid with a
lap time of 6 minutes and 58 seconds
of course not every Porsche customer
will be in a position to achieve times
like that still every driver profits
from a car that handles smoothly even at
top speeds
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the 1950s the Opel capitain was among
the German automotive industry's best
sellers it offered executive class
comfort at an affordable price that was
opals concept and recipe for success and
it secured the capitain third place
among Germany's new car registrations
after its little brother the Opel
Olympia record and the VW Beetle the
dictaphone as car tester Christophe
Bower tells us opals history goes all
the way back to 1862 when Adam Opel
founded a sewing machine and bicycle
manufacturer in 1899 he started turning
out automobiles which led to an emerging
economic expansion by the late 1920s
ovale had a market share of 44% making
it Germany's largest carmaker then came
the Great Depression and in 1929
America's General Motors bought out Opel
but that didn't slow down his business
success one bit image of Dayton effort
into the sky map
in the 1930s Opel rolled upward and
onward to become the biggest car maker
in Europe excelling with such
technological innovations as the
self-supporting unibody starting in 1938
following the Opel Olympia and the cadet
the first capitaine also made use of
this modern design the 6-cylinder sedan
continued almost unchanged right through
the world war 2 until 1953 then it was
time to find a successor just as in the
pre-war years the capitaine of the
1950's quickly secured its place as the
best-selling German six-cylinder car in
three years of production
this version alone found exactly 90 2555
buyers
I'm even Club Christa points out that
every square centimeter of this modern
punt on styling reveals the influence of
the American parent General Motors lots
of chrome lots of shine at the time an
absolute must-have that includes the
wraparound panoramic windshield the
obligatory tail fins and the often
rather garish two-tone paint job
compared to some of its peers this model
is fairly modest Opel took on another
trend from the United States in just six
years from 1953 to 59 the factory rolled
out for different capitain models not
until the 1960s did Opel give up this
rather cache intensive trend for
facelifts this 1955 version of the
capitain differs from its predecessor in
the flattened hood the oval grille and
the larger tail fins and its successor
sported a windshield that wrapped all
the way around to the doors even more
and shinier chrome and even bigger tail
fins
[Music]
an additional 900 Deutsche marks would
buy a luxury version with separate front
seats an imitation leather - a makeup
mirror and lots of styling
[Music]
Crysta points out the one constant with
all the 1950s capitainesj a very quiet
but very robust inline 6-cylinder two
and a half liter engine it had powered
the Opel blitz and it sucked in fuel and
air through only one carburetor that
tended to limit performance by 3900 revs
it had already reached its maximum
output but it was the torque that gave
the car its pick up an impressive 170
newton meters that kicked in at just
1,700 revs and made for a very decent
acceleration
the three-speed transmission with a
steering column mounted gearshift was
made for the shiftless driver and a very
casual driving style fuel consumption
averaged about 11.5 litres not at all
bad for the time
in 1970 after long and dependable
service the capitaine was retired with
honors from then on the top-of-the-range
belonged to the admiral and the diplomat
while the up-and-coming opel commodore
served the mid range master christophe
concludes that for over 30 years the
opel capitaine served well and admirably
nearly half a million were built before
the war was a technological innovator
that set new standards with itself
supporting all steel body in the 1950s
the new generation capitainesj became
darlings of the rising middle class and
symbols of West Germany's economic
miracle as the best-selling six-cylinder
of its time the Opel capitain was
doubtlessly a milestone of automotive
history in the 1980s Opel gave up the
Navy base naming tradition for its Opel
models names like cadet Commodore and
Admiral a tradition that had actually
begun with the Opel capitaine
[Music]
next time on drive it sporty-er and
bigger the new Ford Fiesta and the
Mercedes AMG GT see a dream of a luxury
sport convertible
[Music]